the more you learn about Assad the more
you're forced to come to terms with the
fact that he's half mass murderer and
half your creepy sophomore year roommate
because two years ago a trove of his
emails leaked and all of a sudden the
world had a fascinating glimpse into his
music taste and as the people of Syria
has been fighting and dying for their
freedom their President Bashar al-assad
apparently has been ordering pop music
off iTunes his playlist includes sexy
and I know it by LMFAO LMFAO so we're
dealing with someone with the political
instincts of a young Joseph Stalin and
the music tastes of a 14 year old girl
from Orange County named Tiffany Wow
that song is so har Anna I'm under said
other iTunes purchases were and this is
true a song from Right Said Fred it's so
frustrating that we have powerless to do
anything to hurt him if only there was
something however small that we could do
I guess we could find something he loves
and and turn it against him we could
track down let's say Right Said Fred and
we could hypothetically fly them all the
way over here from London to perform a
specially rewritten anti-assad version
of their greatest hit
that time and expense just for the
momentary catharsis of mildly irritating
one of the worst people on the planet
ladies and gentlemen may I present to
you one of the show al-assad's favorite
bands Right Said Fred
you're too awful for this earth too
awful for this earth so awful it had
your face I barely got a chin it's daddy
got a chin you look just like him so
please stop downloading our tracks stop
downloading our tracks here's your money
back you're a monster
we hit you're a gene and we think you
should be fried for war crime
yeah for war crimes yeah for rock right
here you probably should be on trial or
or by your and the firm ologist not come
out of it
you're just a walking pace Yahoo serous
pain at least nibbler sustained you're a
monster
and a volleyball fans but more than that
your ankle you're an
he's afraid of his mom you're a murderer
mom fear
Oh
so you're an ass oh yeah everyone thinks
you're an ass so all together now you're
an you're an
yeah everyone thinks you're an
stop listening to our song